-Well, guys, the new cast of
the upcoming season of
"The Bachelor"
has just been revealed.
And rules are a little different
this season.
First, all 30 women have to make
it through a House vote.
Then, if approved, they're going
to face a trial in the Senate.
[ Laughter and applause ]
That's right. There's 30 women
on "The Bachelor"
all fighting for
the same thing --
to see who can disappoint
their parents the most.
[ Laughter ]
But this year is very fun.
Since this year's Bachelor
is Pete the pilot,
three of the contestants are
actually flight attendants
[ Audience ohs ]
Which should explain why every
episode starts 45 minutes late
[ Laughter ]
I saw that another
"Bachelor" contestant
is a professional house flipper.
Just a word of advice -- whe
you get to the Bachelor Mansion,
the first thing that you want to
flip is the mattress.
[ Laughter ]
But it looks like a good season.
Here's a photo of
some of the other contestants.
Look at this.
Apparently, to get cast on the
show, you just need to be able
to giggle while
looking over one shoulder.
[ Laughter ]
[ Cheers and applause ]
Can we see that again?
Is it me?
Don't they all look like
they are starring in
a commercial for Yoplait?
[ Laughter ]
Let's get to some news, guys
Tomorrow is
an absolutely historic day
for the United States.
That's right.
After months of anticipation
it's finally here --
"The Masked Singer" finale
[ Laughter and applause ]
We'll have to find out.
Just kidding.
Of course, we all know 'twas
the night before impeachment
and all through D.C.,
Pelosi was clapping
while Trump screamed, "Why me?
[ Laughter ]
That's right.
Tomorrow the House
will officially vote on
the articles of impeachmen
against President Trump,
and Nancy Pelosi
apparently has the votes.
Then Hillary was like --
[ Cheers and applause ]
Then Hillary was like,
"Well, don't get too cocky."
[ Laughter ]
And, of course,
the media is fired up too.
This morning in the NBC gym,
I ran into Mika Brzezinski
bench-pressing "Morning Joe.
Yeah.
[ Laughter ]
Everyone is talking about this
Today, "happy impeachment"
was trending on Twitter.
When Trump saw that,
he was like, "Trust me,
after tomorrow's vote,
everyone will be saying
'merry impeachment' again.
[ Laughter ]
As if things weren't tense
enough today,
Trump sent a six-page letter
to Nancy Pelosi,
where he called the impeachmen
an unprecedented and
unconstitutional abuse of power,
claimed Pelosi
offended Americans,
and calls his crimes "completely
disenuous, meritless,
and baseless invention
of your imagination."
When asked why he sent
the letter, Trump said,
"Because Pelosi
blocked me on Twitter."
[ Laughter ]
Meanwhile, Rudy Giuliani
just did an interview
where he admitted that Trump
knew what he was
doing in Ukraine.
It's almost like Rudy hear
there's no way Trump could b
removed from office and thought,
"Oh, yeah,
we'll see about that."
[ Laughter ]
Seriously, I'm not saying Rudy
is hurting Trump's case,
but even Harvey Weinstein thinks
he needs to shut up and go away.
[ Audience ohs ]
But Trump is busy.
Today he hosted the Presiden
and First Lady of Guatemala.
First, Trump was confused.
He was like, "I love Guatemala
especially when they make it
table side."
[ Laughter ]
"It's extra at Chipotle."
And finally, as if there wasn'
enough going on,
a Russian spy ship
was just spotted
sailing off
the coast of Florida.
Trump heard that and was like,
"That's not a spy ship.
That's my getaway vehicle.
We have a great show tonight